Jennifer is with us in Providence Rhode
Island hi Jennifer how are you I'm
wonderful Dave how are you better than I
deserve what's up I'm in a big find my
husband and I are mom we're trying to
get out of debt we had about $43,000 and
consumer debt including her Carlos in
the mortgage and I just cannot seem to
get my husband on board
he's been nagging me we've been
organizing for 10 years he's been
driving me clean about buying a boat and
he wants a boat everything about a boat
and I just want to get out of that
desperately and it's pretty a very big
strain on our marriage
I just need your help you're doing that
you're paying all the bills aren't you
you need to change that into say I'm
sick and tired of paying the bills by
myself honey you're going to sit down
here with me and you're going to help me
look at this
budget and where this money is going I'm
tired of making all the decisions I
don't want be your mommy because he's
coming to you like he's coming to you
like a little boy asking for money and
he works and earns money and then he
asks you for money and he feels like
you're like you're his mommy and mommy
saying he can't have a boat and little
boys having a fit well instead let's
make him a man and let him help you the
two of you is too grown-up sit down and
look at the money that's coming in and
the money that's going out and what our
dreams and our goals in this household
are boats aren't bad boats aren't evil I
own two of them but you know when you're
$40,000 in debt and your wife stressed
out you want to buy a boat you're acting
like a little child but the reason is is
he doesn't have any information and he's
not felt the weight of the
responsibility of this household because
you've been carrying it all by yourself
for him great and I've been trying to
educate him I write all I want to
educate him I don't want to educate him
I want to put this on him where it
breaks his kneecaps because he feels the
weight and the pressure and the stress
that you've been feeling and it puts him
on his knees with you because it's
crushing you
yes it is yeah I want to crush him a
little I'm feel that way with you and
then the two of you get up under this
thing and look at it and go yeah and I
mean I did what you were feeling here
I'm so sorry
yeah we'll get this debt paid off and
then we'll get our boat which would be
the proper order of adults doing things
not children right right I agree a
hundred percent a man set him down say
we're gonna do a budget together if he
will not sit down with you and help you
with making the financial decisions for
the household you do not have a
financial problem anymore now you have a
marriage problem then you need to see a
marriage counselor but I think all it is
is you've been carrying all this for him
and I want you to stop it today once you
call a budget meeting tonight so honey
here's the bills get them all out look
out and start writing them down and say
help me figure this out I mean you want
to skip evicted you want us to retire
and eat Alpo how these kids going to eat
I'm trying to figure this out by myself
and you around I want to float so let's
set the boat aside ferment you're going
to help me be a man here and help me
with the decisions in this household
that'll be an interesting conversation
this is the Dave Ramsey show hey guys
thanks for watching if you enjoyed this
video click the subscribe button to get
the latest content and check out these
other great clips from the show
[Music]